five men and women who are working on a
half to get healthy bill rather than a
be healthy bill thank you Richard well
you know there has been a lot of focus
on you know when you're healthy your
insurance is likely to be very cheap
you're not expensive for the insurance
companies to cover and the issue is
really folks who have you know long term
health care problems that are very
expensive to cover and the issue that
neither Republicans or Democrats have
been able to solve is what do we want to
do about those folks there's an
interesting story there is a patient in
Iowa who costs a million dollars a month
to insure and this patient is just
skewing the entire Iowa healthcare
market insurers don't want to be there
because there's this million dollar a
month patient who is you know increasing
everybody's premiums and you know you
can argue that not everybody should
carry that cost but what do we do about
that million dollar a month patient do
we as you know country say you know
we're not going to cover your healthcare
I think society has decided we're not
going to do that but in a policy sense
neither Republicans nor Democrats have
come up with a way to to ensure that
that patient has access to health care
but everybody else can afford their
premiums and it's really it's really a
problem both parties don't have an
answer to our guest a graduate of
Marquette University she began covering
business for The Washington Times and
now on the healthcare beat her work
available at politico.com John from
Beaverton Oregon good morning good
morning and and Jennifer here your
graduate from the fine Jesuit
institution I wanted to point out I'm a
Democrat my uncle is a Republican he
works in southern Illinois on a rural
health center
I work for a FQHC here in Portland
Oregon we can talk about health care
hey that's bipartisan what is keeping
the Senate and the house and then also
the Catholic Bishops have fort
come out against what's come out of the
Republican House and Senate and also
there the CAJ the AMA and other
associations that actually deal with
health care have come out against this
Thank You John we'll get a response yeah
the color is is a good point most of the
major health care organizations have
come out against the Republican bill
many of them supported the Affordable
Care Act including the American Medical
Association a lot of the major hospital
groups and right now their concern is
they don't want to see folks uninsured I
mean it hospitals have a huge interest
in seeing their patients covered of
course that's a financial interest they
don't want to have to cover patients who
don't have insurance
physicians oppose the the Republican
bills right now they supported the
Affordable Care Act and as far as the
caller's question on the you know
partisan nature of these conversations I
think the Affordable Care Act's passage
seven years ago just drove both parties
into their respective camps there was
really no middle ground there was no
Republican who supported the Affordable
Care Act and both parties were able to
stake a lot of a lot of ground in that
so if you are a Republican for the last
seven years you had to oppose Obamacare
and if you didn't you've probably got a
primary and you're probably not in
Washington right now and if you are a
Democrat you know you saw all these
attacks on the Affordable Care Act and
you kind of dug in your heels and said
you know this this we've been fighting
for this we were fighting for universal
coverage for 50 something years we're
gonna stick with it and I think since
President Obama left office they become
even more emboldened in ensuring that
that legacy is not going to go away and
that that's driven a lot of this let me
go through a couple of real quick tweets
this is from Vivian who says this GOP
bill is not a health care bill it's a
tax cut bill for rich donors yeah
there's some to that there was a big tax
on high-income earners in the Affordable
Care Act which helped pay for the bill
the Republicans want to eliminate that
tax that there has been a criticism that
they're really just wrong repealing that
tax and driving a cost for low-income
folks
Senator Susan Collins and center bob
Corker moderates in the Senate have
called to keep that tax in Obamacare in
order to help low income people whether
it's you know in some kind of premium
reduction program or something like that
that's an idea that McConnell has taken
into consideration we could see that
kind of a change in the bill if it
actually gets released and revised in
July I think one of the concerns there
that you know Republicans are trying to
come up with money to further reduce
premiums also they are cognizant of that
criticism that the person on Twitter put
out there you know if this is just
viewed as a bill that increases costs
for low-income folks and eliminates
taxes for rich folks it's not hard to
see how the politics of that will play
out in the 2018 election and Beyond
which is what Steve is tweeting about
the house could fall to the Democrats
even with gerrymandering in 2018 partly
on health care yeah I think it's going
to be a huge issue in 2018 no matter
what happens to this legislation as you
know the house already voted on this
bill so House members are already on the
record in support or opposition to this
and I think in you know we can discuss
whether the house is actually in play
because of things like gerrymandering
but it's definitely going to be a huge
issue we're definitely going to see this
in 2018 and so far you know this is the
only thing Washington has really been
working on so there's isn't much more to
talk about at this point we welcome our
listeners on c-span radio and those
listening on Sirius XM Christine from
Astoria New York Democrats line good
morning good morning the arguments
they're making in favor of their repeal
bill are not they're pretty ridiculous
such as they're always talking about the
free market and competition in the
insurance market and in the states where
there's one or insurer that they need
more competition it doesn't make sense
but if there's only one insurer in that
state well that can't make a profit
that's it's it's a market failure that
how how is competition going to make a
better situation in those phases even
one insurer can't make a profit Thank
You Christine so the issue there
Republicans are making the argument that
this is a free market solution in that
if they eliminate some of Obama cares
regulations insurers will coming back
into the market they'll start trying to
you know offer policies again there are
several states where insurers are not
offering plans because you know they
either feel like it's not a good
financial opportunity or whatever the
reason is there are states where there's
only one insurance company so you don't
have options and so this is the argument
Republicans are making that the
counter-argument is that if you
eliminate all the regulations that
insurers don't like that insurers will
be able to cherry-pick again and that if
you are sick or have some kind of
pre-existing condition it'll be harder
for you to get coverage
Howard is next from Illinois Republican
line with Jennifer haberkorn at Politico
Howard good morning yes go ahead please
yes Jennifer yeah I think I could solve
a healthcare problem with two simple
statements give us the same health care
that our politicians have at the price
they pay for it yeah this is a really
common criticism I hear and a lot of
folks really like this idea of having
the same coverage as their member of
Congress members of Congress right now
are under the Affordable Care Act for
the most part unless they found some
other insurance such as through a spouse
but under the affordable care act they
were kicked out of the plan that federal
employees get and they had to go on the
Obamacare exchanges so most of them get
coverage through the exchange here in DC
some folks decided to go home and go on
their home state exchange so that they
can tell their constituents they're on
the same plan as their member as as
their voters and you know I've asked a
lot of members of Congress what they
think of their plan predictably it falls
under party lines Democrats like it
Republicans don't but they you know they
they see the same price tag as as you
are I would if we were and be on the
exchange members of Congress do get some
financial help for their plan because
there are federal employees so if they
buy through the
exchange here in Washington DC the
federal government does pay a portion of
their bill as their employer
you know most major employers do you pay
a portion of your employee health care
plan and that's the case here let's go
to Georgia
Kenny is on the phone independent line
good morning right so if the Congress is
truly representative of the country then
why is the GOP to 450 plus the
vice-president I mean that's like the
skin of your teeth man half the country
is not gonna like it and that's how
small they're willing to go do they
really consider that a win it's my
comment thank you
Thank You Kenny yeah it's a good point I
mean Republicans particularly in the
Senate are right on the edge there's 52
Republicans Mitch McConnell we need 50
for this to pass and you know at the
beginning of the year they thought they
would have 52 now it seems like this is
definitely going to be a 50/50 vote if
Republicans are even successful at
getting to that point the Vice President
Mike Pence would have to come in break
that tie as the president of the Senate
and you know I think there's you know a
bit of politics behind the caller's
question you know the Affordable Care
Act was extremely divisive there's a
poll that the Kaiser Family Foundation
does every single month on the
Affordable Care Act asked a lot of
questions including favorable
unfavorable opinion and those poll
numbers were really stuck in concrete
for seven years if that law was slightly
more unfavorable than favorable and that
really didn't change it until the repeal
effort became a plausibility and at that
point it became slightly more favorable
so I think that's weighing on every
Republican who's considering voting for
this bill that you know whatever they do
here is going to be remembered you know
in the short term by their voters and in
the long term and it will be a skin on
your tooth vote I'm gonna ask you in a
moment about the process of this week
what we can expect we'll go to Maxine
joining us from Shelby North Carolina
good morning Republican line
good morning what I wanted to ask is
about the Medicaid expansion Carolina
didn't expand their Medicaid program and
my sister is a director of patient
patient manager at Shelby hospitals and
but most of the doctors do not around
here do not take Medicaid so the
patients end up in the emergency room
anyway so I'm wondering why there's such
a fight over the expansion of Medicaid
when I don't know if they've done the
study or what but most doctors refused
to take Medicaid patients so they end up
in the emergency room anyway which
Obamacare was supposed to take care of
that Thank You Maxie sure thank you for
the call this is a huge problem as well
the Supreme Court in 2012 gave States
the option of expanding Medicaid Obama
care was supposed to expand Medicaid all
over the country this became an option
it became a huge political issue in
every state every governor had to decide
do I expand Medicaid and bracing the
Affordable Care Act or do I not and in
states like North Carolina that did not
expand Medicaid there are some folks who
you know are in a gap they don't qualify
for Medicaid they don't qualify for the
benefits of the Affordable Care Act and
they're really stuck in this position
where nothing really is provided for
them under this law that was supposed to
help everybody it was one of the kind of
big failures of the Affordable Care Act
once the Supreme Court ruled and so I
think in the Republican bill they are
trying to repair that they would let
more folks qualify for subsidies but the
issue with physicians not accepting
Medicaid has been a long-standing
problem predating the Affordable Care
Act it's probably going to post-date
this bill some physicians argue that
Medicaid doesn't reimburse that rates
high enough for them to make it
financially viable to to take Medicaid
patients and in some parts of the
country that's particularly acute and
with regard to insurance companies
there's this from Roger who said did the
Affordable Care Act guarantee insurance
companies a 15% profit margin no it did
not
there is a requirement in the Affordable
Care Act that insurers have to spend 85%
of what they take in in premiums on
health care and if it's more than I
should say less than that you as a
patient would get a rebate so that might
be what he's talking about but that 15%
is for administrative costs and
addition to profit not just profit
Brenda is next st. Louis Missouri good
morning Democrats line good morning good
morning Jennifer what my question is
I read that in the new tax bill that
they're trying to pass for health care
that the Senate the Congress and their
employees are excluded from having the
same insurance that we would have that
was an issue in the House bill the house
did not it would have essentially undone
what Obamacare did which made members of
Congress get the same insurance as us
the Senate bill would keep that
provision it would keep members of
Congress in Obama care plans whether
that changes to be determined but as of
right now members of Congress would
still be on plans in the exchanges just
like a lot of Americans lombardo joining
us I'm Salt Lake City independent line
good morning hey Jennifer thanks for
taking my call I am interested in
finding out if it would be possible to
have the insurance I mean the government
creates an insurance arm for those that
are uninsurable if the political
environment allowed it yeah this has
come up several times in the debate over
health care this would be something like
a public option that which would
essentially the government would provide
insurance to folks directly and this has
never really taken off because a lot of
a lot of conservatives even a lot of
independents don't really like the idea
of government in your health care which
of course is a little ironic because
Medicare is essentially a government-run
health care program and it's extremely
popular no politician is going to you
know ever suggest taking away Medicare
and so it's kind of become a favorite of
liberals progressives some kind of
public option Medicare for all or
expanding Medicare be under 65 years old
but I really don't see that becoming a
political viability anytime soon so in
terms of what happens next you mentioned
senator Susan Collins a more moderate
Republic
and the more conservative Republicans
like Ted Cruz and Rand Paul very
critical of the legislation so where
does that put the bill what's the
process this week and potentially next
week so Mitch McConnell right now is
trying to get to that 50 votes that we
talked about he has to decide do I
either go after the moderates like Susan
Collins make changes to the bill make it
more than middle or do I go after folks
like Ted Cruz Rand Paul Mike Lee make it
more conservative I think right now he's
trying to thread that needle because you
know we've already mentioned that's four
senators right off the bat and he can
only lose two he has made changes to the
bill already he's at an opioid funding
which is something that the moderates
want he's asked this Congressional
Budget Office to score policies that the
conservatives like which would allow
insurance companies that offer plans
under the Affordable Care Act to also
offer non-compliant plans essentially
this would provide cheaper coverage less
thorough coverage it to folks and you
know whether whether McConnell can find
you know that magic bill that gets 250
votes still to be determined as of right
now I'm very skeptical that that even
exists because there's just too many
folks who have too many issues with this
bill and further complicating all of
this senator Dean Heller who's up for
re-election and for a brief period of
time facing criticism within his own
party and from a pro Trump political
action committee yeah Dean Heller is
probably the most vulnerable Republican
senator up in 2018 and she came out
right after the Senate bill was passed
and said I can't do this his state
expanded Medicaid his governor is a big
fan of the Medicaid expansion doesn't
want to see it undone and how it really
attached himself to the governor and
said you know if if the governor doesn't
like this Medicaid rollback I can't get
behind it either
it really hurts people in my home state
so Heller was gonna be a very hard vote
to get on board making it even more
difficult as you mentioned a super PAC
aligned with the white house came out
with ads against Heller almost
immediately after that press conference
those ads have since been retracted and
McConnell's trying to get heller back
into the fold
trying to get his vote back into the mix
but I think Heller is gonna be a very
hard person to get on board and one
final senator rob portman of Ohio you
mentioned the heroin and opioid epidemic
that is a key issue for him he's been
wavering a little bit yeah he's also
he's worried a lot about the opioid
problem he's also worried about Medicaid
expansion his state did expand Medicaid
again under a Republican governor who
really went out on a limb Governor John
Kasich and embraced the Affordable Care
Act to expand Medicaid Rob Portman has
kind of led a group of Republicans from
a decade expansion states to try to stop
the Medicaid expansion rollback or at
least to slow it down to the point where
it's further into the future he's going
to be hard about to get to but bottom
line you do not expect a vote this week
no the Congressional Budget Office isn't
back with scores on some of these
proposals I think you know the
Republican leaders wanted a vote this
week I think maybe the week after that
could be a possibility but I don't I
think we'll be here the night before
August recess starts may be talking
about a health care bill we will follow
your reporting at politico.com Jennifer
haberkorn
as always thank you very much with
Benghazi and possible action by the
Senate on the health care law
replacement was a topic on the sunday
news shows will show you remarks from
three Republican senators about the
future of the legislation Ted Cruz bill
Cassidy and John McCain and after that
we're going to open up the phone lines
and take your calls live about what you
think of the future of the health care
law you the consumer should be able to
choose what healthcare you want to buy
if you want to buy a plan with all the
bells and whistles with all of the
mandates under title one you can buy
that plan those plans will be on the
market those plans will have significant
federal taxpayer money behind them but
on the other hand if you can't afford a
full Cadillac plan you should be able to
buy another plan that meets your needs
and so the consumer freedom option gives
you the consumer choice whether to go
with the full Cadillac or a skinnier
plan that's a lot more affordable and
for a lot of consumers that may be
be much better than having no coverage
whatsoever know what happens if it
doesn't it seems like we have two
different paths being talked about right
now you've got Senator McConnell in
Kentucky last week saying listen if this
fails you've got to go work with
Democrats to shore up the insurance
markets
you've got President Trump and and Steve
venusian just saying no we should move
to the repeal then replace option what's
your answer
I agree with the president and indeed
that's something Mike Lee and I both
urged back in January we pointed out
that Congress has voted 40 50 60 times
to repeal Obamacare and Mike Lee and I
both said all right let's start with the
language in 2015 the trust about every
Republican voted for in both houses
let's pass that have it go into effect a
year or two years from now and then
spend that time debating the replacement
I'm all for people being able to choose
the insurance plan that best suits their
needs we should absolutely do that but
you're right if you sluice off the older
and sicker in their own plan with their
own risk pool then you've just recreated
the Obamacare exchanges where the
federal taxpayer is putting billions in
to subsidize the expense of a few we
need to have a common risk pool where
everybody chips in a little bit for that
young person who gets in a car wreck for
example if we do it in that case the
Cruz amendments a good amendment
but as it now stands Cruz's a
non-starter for you I don't know the
amendment if it turns out to plans but
that's what he's described with no
that's okay with two risk pools then
that's bad the graduate student
described no he has not yet designated
whether or not you have a single risk
pool or two risk pools if it is a single
risk pool that actually works if it is
two risk pools that's just Obamacare
recreated if Republican senators are
unable to pass what they are working on
now they should immediately repeal and
then replace at a later date what do you
think of that non-starter I'll tell you
it'll be uncertainty and the insurance
markets premiums will rise for
middle-class families it gives all the
power to people who actually don't
believe in president Trump's campaign
pledges who actually don't want to
continue to cover and care for
pre-existing conditions and to lower
premiums it gives them the stronger hand
I think it's wrong I think it betrays
president Trump's campaign pledges what
do we need to do now go back to the
beginning
a bill introduced a bill move it through
bring it to the floor vote on it that's
the normal process and if you shut out
the the adversary or the the opposite
party you're going to end up the same
way Obamacare did when they rammed it
through with sixty votes only guess what
we don't have 60 votes John so what
happens now on health care next weekend
I think my view is it's probably gonna
be dead but I am I've been wrong I
thought I'd be president I today but I
think I think I fear that it's gonna
fail and then we should say convene a
Republican conversation what are we
going to do introduce a bill say the
Democrats here's a bill it doesn't mean
they don't right that they control it it
means they can have amendments
considered and even when they lose then
they're part of the process that's what
democracy is supposed to be all about
and there is the capital of the United
States on a beautiful Sunday afternoon
tomorrow afternoon the Senate will be
back at work in the Capitol and one of
the subjects of course this week we
expect to come up at some point is the
health care law we want to know what you
think
what should the Senate do when they
return to Washington about health care
we thought we would throw up our phone
lines and open them up to you this
afternoon you can see the numbers right
there on your screen and we'll start out
with a call from Birmingham Alabama on
our line for Democrats it's Paula
hi Paula you're on c-span what should
the Senate do tomorrow or any time when
they come back about health care Paul
are you there yes go ahead what should
the Senate do what should Congress do I
am which listen Germany and I was over
there you know people didn't pay
anything for medicine or going to the
House bill but right now they raised the
taxes I think five six seven percent and
right now when they have to get medicine
they paid like five six dollars for the
medicine and when they go in the house
till they don't have to pay anything
because they take it from the Texas
stairways and I listed it the
Republicans would do something like that
you know where people don't have to
worry about gain a whole bunch when they
have to go to hospital or got to the
emergency room or anything that's what I
like for them to do I'm kind of nervous
that's the first time I will call they
don't anything like that well we
appreciate your call thank you very much
let's move on to Rebekah calling on our
line for Republicans from Massachusetts
go ahead Rebecca welcome to c-span yes
my first time so I'm very happy to get
through one of the things that has come
up so many times is about social
security and I am on Social Security it
covers very little but what most people
I don't think anyone ever brings up is
they think that Social Security is free
every senior pays a hundred and five
dollars a month for their health care
and they really don't get anything they
have to go to an extra plan and also
being from Massachusetts I as a was as a
senior but a very low income senior was
on what we call MassHealth Medicare
which was supposed to be what Obamacare
was done Massachusetts did it maybe it
should be done at the state level all
states doing it at a state level because
as soon as Obamacare came in I was
kicked off a MassHealth I have a
disability it's not a major disability
but I I I was on it because of that and
because I'm low income and when I got
kicked off of MassHealth I also got
kicked off of my drug plan so I think
that people should take a look I was
listening this morning I liked senator
Cassidy's and
the counterpart his counterpart from
Maine dozen I always forget what our
lettuce plant is putting it to the state
and I like that plan all right well
thank you Rebecca thank you for your
call we're going to move on to Ron in
Mount Pleasant Texas on our line for
others Ron your thoughts about health
care and specifically what you think
Congress should do with anything at all
well actually I think that Congress
should go ahead and do what President
Trump suggested and just repeal the ACA
because I'm a social worker here in
Texas and I see thousands of people that
are looking for doctors that have
Medicaid to Obamacare and there is no
doctor within a 500-mile radius that
will see these patients so Ron you're
talking about the same idea that senator
Ben Sasse of Nebraska has floated to
repeal and replace later is that what
you're talking about
well yes but I have a way that it could
be fixed I had Washington could fix the
problem and it would be by just
legislative activity it could be passing
like two or three laws in Congress one
that insurance companies would have to
cover pre-existing conditions and pass
another law that children would stay on
their parents health care plan until
they were age 26 and open up the markets
across state lines where you could buy
from any insurance company any state so
that there would be healthy competition
and I believe that rates would go
drastically down just repeal the ACA
pass like three laws which Washington is
the hesitant to do because of the
lobbyists for the instrument as laws
against the insurance companies for fear
there
or profit margin but I don't see that
happening at all all right tell you what
Ron we appreciate your call I wanted to
remind folks that coming up this evening
on newsmakers we'll learn a bit more
because we'll have Richard [ __ ] and
in fact Ron kind of mentioned some of
the the lobbyists if you will he as
Richard is the president and CEO of the
American Hospital Association and he'll
be joining us to talk about Republican
efforts to repeal and replace the
Affordable Care Act that six o'clock
eastern time right here on c-span again
newsmakers tonight with Richard Pollak
of the American Hospital Association
let's go over to Ames Iowa are aligned
for Democrats with Gail hi Gail you're
on c-span on a Sunday afternoon what do
you think I think that it should not be
repealed I think that I am because I am
on a lot of us are on Social Security
disability we cannot afford as it is my
my medication there's a lot of times
where I get I almost cannot afford my
medication and as far as you know the
elderly I think that they need to vote
to keep Obamacare and act in place
because I for one the Obamacare since
they had gotten it on has been better
off for me myself personally all right
we appreciate the call let's go over to
Robert in Dundee Illinois on our line
for others Robert hi there you're on the
air what do you think about the health
care law and what should be done well
Republicans just you know get together
replace Obamacare or add to it there's a
lot of
singing people that are in fixed incomes
and we're going Bart he's all wrong he
should not recess in August and work
this thing out all right so you're
saying you should stay here in
Washington until they work something out
Pam are lying for Democrats from Flint
Michigan what do you think oh yes
well actually what the hell some I know
all you guys are educated you understand
economics just like I do don't replace
that bill fix it
what's wrong with fixing Obamacare go
through there and fix what need to be
fixing
nothing should happen to Social Security
Social Security was has been paying for
itself forever but government of the US
has borrowed that money don't change
that you hurt a lot of elderly people
that are disabled
all right Pam we appreciate that call
let's go over to Mike in Berlin Maryland
he's calling on our line for for
Republicans go ahead Mike you're on
c-span hi there enjoy your service
you're doing a great thing for America
number one they should repeal repeal as
they said the health care act that they
have and start from scratch the plan
that the Republicans have is a disgrace
to the poor people in this country it's
just been handed over to the insurance
companies I think we should have control
on the insurance companies in this
country they have to cooperate also
they're very rich they control the
country they have all the power and the
insurance company dominates our whole
society
they're leaving Medicaid out which
really hurts the very very very poor
people okay and they can't do that
that's a disgrace of humanity and the
Republicans have really let us down the
Republican Congress both Paul Ryan and
Mitch McConnell there are very weak
leaders they are not good statesmen let
me ask you this Mike you called on our
line for Republicans if the Republicans
don't do something between now in the
midterm elections in 2018 what do you
think happens to the Republican majority
in the House let's say well there's no
party as you know when the when the boys
came in a night in 2012 those hotshots
including Ted Cruz and Roby know and
that bunch they really Frank there's 40
of em who fractured the party and the
people like John McCain and hatch the
old people have been there forever
should be out because they can't control
the party anymore and the Republican
Party is done and it's really a this is
a joke the company in the country is
being run by a very good president dr.
Donald Trump Don was leading America
right now the new Republican Congress it
did all right Mike thank you for your
call we're going to move on we just got
a minute or so left we'll try and give
the last word this time around to Samuel
from Yuba City California is that right
Samuel that's correct
Yuba City go ahead what do you think
about health care you get the last word
this time I think the Congress should
repeal Obamacare and give every American
from birth to death Medicare and
Medicaid I'm a physician we have the
money in this country to do that the
Pentagon's budget alone could take care
of all of that eliminate the insurance
companies completely I have worked in
County health care taking care of the
poor all my medical career this could be
done that's if the people in Congress
have any gumption whatsoever any courage
whatsoever and they are concerned about
the American people eliminate the
insurance companies give everyone
including the congressman birth to death
Medicare and Medicaid that will solve
the problem
all right Samuel thank you for your call
this is a conversation we will continue
here on c-span part of that conversation
tonight six o'clock Eastern with Richard
Pollock on newsmakers he's the president
and CEO of the American Hospital
Association he'll talk about the
Republican efforts to repeal and replace
the Affordable Care Act he'll also talk
about the Democrats efforts to keep the
health care law and he'll talk about
Medicaid and hospital costs that again
six o'clock Eastern here tonight on
c-span of course next chance for you to
get in on the phone conversation would
be tomorrow morning 7:00 a.m. Eastern on
Washington Journal time now for a
journalist and author Molly Hemingway
talking about the relationship between
the Trump administration and the media
she is a senior editor at the online
magazine The Federalist she's also the
author of the book Trump versus the
media and this runs about an hour good
evening welcome I'm Matthew Spalding I'm
associate vice president and Dean for
Hillsdale College here in Washington DC
this is our campus our local campus as
you all well know the main campuses in
Michigan the college was founded in 1844
by men and women grateful to God for the
great blessings of civil liberty and
believed that the diffusion of learning
was the best way to perpetuate those
blessings and so it's existed there for
170 years or so rejecting any government
support it has provided education for
all regardless of their race their creed
or their color here in Washington DC we
host students and public events like
this one and do our best to try to teach
political staff and members of Congress
about constitutional governments and the
practice and principles of American
constitutionalism you learn more about
Hillsdale in the Kirby Center and about
our online courses at Hillsdale edu or
talk this evening is about president
Trump and the media or perhaps I should
say more correctly President Trump
versus the media he was criticized
recently for one of his tweets he
responded that his use of social medias
not presidential
it's modern-day presidential indeed it
seems an important aspect of his
presidency both in his candidacy and now
in the White House an important aspect
of his relationship shall we say with
the media is central to that presidency
what are we to make of all this what
does it tell us about the media
Molly Hemingway is a senior editor at
The Federalist a longtime journalist her
work has appeared in The Wall Street
Journal USA Today the Los Angeles Times
The Guardian Washington Post CNN
National Review federal times and I
could go on she's a frequent guest on
Fox News CNN and National Public Radio
she's recently written for encounter
books a broadside called Trump versus
the media and here I have to commend my
friend Roger Kimball who's the publisher
of encounter books for reviving the idea
of a broadside something that was very
popular at the time of the American
Revolution she's written Lee recently
written this broadside for counter books
on our top of this evening Trump versus
the media please join me in welcoming
Molly Hemingway
thank you very much dr. Spaulding and my
husband Mark and I had the pleasure of
being Eugene C Pulliam visiting fellows
at Hillsdale last year we were so
impressed with Hillsdale the journalism
students we met there learning more
about the the college that you have
there so this is a great time to talk
about this topic and CNN has had a rough
go of it recently they're one of the big
media companies that has pushed a Russia
Trump collusion or conspiracy story line
since January these stories have been
built almost exclusively around
anonymous sources who promised major
scandal but continually failed to
deliver in some cases the anonymous
sources are not to be trusted in any way
shape or form such as those who were
familiar with the former FBI director
Comey's thinking and they told CNN
journalists that Comey would testify
under oath that he never told Donald
Trump he was not under investigation
much less three times in fact that's
precisely what Comey testified under
oath that he had thrice told the
president he was not under investigation
a week or two after that story disaster
the cable outlet had to retract a story
publish an apology and three employees
resigned after yet another of these Red
Scare stories based exclusively on
anonymous sources turned out not to be
true and then this week we saw that CNN
chose to use its power and might to go
after borderline blackmail the guy who
may have inspired or originally created
a video idea that President Donald Trump
tweeted out it's weird to say this but
that video was showing a fake Donald
Trump fake beating up a guy with a CNN
logo for a head in a fake wrestling
match there was a somewhat really minor
thing that caught my eye yesterday that
I'd like to begin with CNN tweeted out
quotes from notable Americans about
freedom of the press and related topics
on Independence Day one of the quotes
they tweeted from Abraham Lincoln was in
error it was let the people know the
facts and the country will be safe
the tweet storm this collection of
quotes from CNN was widely interpreted
as yet another attack on President
Donald Trump the independent ran a story
about it headlined CNN taunts Trump on
July 4 with Abraham Lincoln quote on
facts theater critic Terry Teachout had
a funny feeling about the quote he dug
into it it turned out that the quote was
inaccurate and even so it was based on
hearsay the real or hearsay quote was
let them know the truth and the country
is safe in context it was about public
opinion that sometimes being so against
the civil war due to what Lincoln said
was people being misled that they would
have accepted disunion over a continued
fight to victory
so the fake quote referred to facts the
real or the hair say quote referred to
truth and it's a perfect conflation or
error for journalists for CNN to make
and one that speaks to modern
journalism's problems facts can be
manipulated truth is much more difficult
to attain so it might be factual that
Obama's intelligence chiefs briefed
president-elect Trump about a Russian
dossier for instance but whether that
fact is used to spin a Russian
conspiracy hoax is where truthfulness is
important it reminds me of the John
Peter Zenger trial of 1735 probably
learned about this in elementary school
successfully argued by Andrew Hamilton
the trial was an important symbolic
event in the development of American
freedom of expression remembered chiefly
for Hamilton's now famous plea that
truth should be admitted as a defense
that wasn't permitted in the English
system but he successfully got the jury
to decide in his favor on that point the
trial was as David Paul Nord has written
a disputation on truth and how truth is
revealed to man the press in America
have been accorded a variety of perks
and privileges based on the belief that
seeking and speaking truth are necessary
aspects of Liberty and on the
assumptions that the press were integral
to the success of civil society that
they would exercise their power
responsibly
however Trump's victory has advanced the
developing realization among many
Americans that the media have completely
abdicated their responsibility and shown
themselves hostile to the values ideas
that many Americans hold much of the
population no longer believes the media
should be treated deferentially and
given the power to shape much less
control public opinion so complaining
about bias in the media is a Republican
tradition going back many decades at
least to Dwight Eisenhower's 1964
convention speech when he bashed the
media and received a prolonged standing
ovation and nearly every appearance that
President George HW Bush made in his
re-election campaign he would hold up
this bumper sticker that he said it was
his favorite annoy the media reelect
Bush it said and the crowd would hoot
and holler because everybody kind of
knew that the media were biased against
him and that they they favored Bill
Clinton political candidates is
different as Richard Nixon and John
McCain have all complained about this
issue conservative talk radio hosts have
spent years dissecting the framing and
and and angle on each story and
conservatives have complained so much
about media bias that it has become
trite
journalists accepted the complaints as
part of doing business and they made
little to no apparent effort to improve
in fact they got worse at some point
something just broke in the booklet I in
the in the broadside I go through some
examples of major media mistakes that
caused a breakdown in trust one which
some of you might be too young to
remember was media coverage of the Duke
University lacrosse teams alleged gang
rape of an exotic dancer the three men
she'd accused were not just found not
guilty eventually but actually declared
innocent which is a very rare thing to
have happen in a trial but the media had
reported on it as if they were guilty as
sin convicting the men of rape racism
and who knows what else the media used
the alleged incident to force a national
conversation about the need to accept
all manner of politically correct
liberal Piatt DS or there was the
treatment of the tea party were
legitimate concerns about the size and
scope of about the expansion of the size
and scope of the federal government were
treated as the contemptuous and
irrational yobs of the racist Republican
grassroots protesters who showed up at
town halls were disparaged as mentally
hinged and possibly violent there was in
2010 the revelation of journalists a
secret email list where hundreds of
journalists shaped narratives to help
then Democratic candidate Barack Obama
these participants included mainstream
reporters and liberal journalists and
they again shaped the narratives I think
a big break happened with the candidacy
of Mitt Romney with President Trump in
Poland today we might remember when Mitt
Romney was on a foreign trip during his
his campaign and you had reporters from
CNN Washington Post and New York Times
chasing after him I don't even remember
what the supposed problem was but they
were shouting at him what about your
gaffes I was screaming it and you had
candy crowley helping obama with when
mitt romney had him on the ropes over
benghazi during a debate you had Mitt
Romney's efforts to make sure he had
good qualified women in his
administration in mana in Massachusetts
treated as if it were something very
misogynistic with binders full of women
being shorthand for his war on women
when he talked about the problem of
removing work requirement work
requirements from welfare he was called
a racist again Republican and
conservative voters are used to this
even someone is previously beloved by
the media as John McCain was slowly
transformed into Hitler like
representation during his campaign
against Obama but when it happened to
Mitt Romney a squeaky-clean unfailingly
nice completely moderate Mormon from
Massachusetts Republicans realized that
the media would do it too literally
anyone the same time you had Obama
scandals during the first and second
term they were barely covered much less
given the regular breathless attention
that political scandals are normally
given when the Internal Revenue Service
revealed that actors in the agency some
of whom were frequent visitors to the
White House are in frequent contact with
the White House had targeted
conservative opponents of Obama and
limited their ability to gain tax-exempt
status who was treated as if it was
really no big deal
largely passed under the radar even
though for many Americans it was a
scandal that eclipsed Watergate many
times over and it's not just politics
media figures can't hide their contempt
for Americans who do not share the same
progressive values as they do whether
it's roaming the countryside trying to
find cake Baker's or pizza shop owners
who they can highlight for not sharing
the same views on sexual ethics or going
back even to 1990 when the LA Times had
a study looking at how abortion was
covered in the media actually published
in the Los Angeles Times by David Shaw
showed that they frame the abortion
debate in terms favorable to those who
support the practice they quote abortion
right advocates more frequently and
favorably than opponents they ignore and
give minimal attention to events and
issues favorable to abortion opponents
we saw that most recently with how they
covered or rather covered up the Planned
Parenthood organ harvesting scandal and
it's also exactly what happened in 2013
when Philadelphia abortionist Kermit
Gosnell was on trial for the murders of
some of the children in women whose
lives he ended in his filthy clinic he
kept trophies of baby feed in jars his
employees testified that he snipped the
spinal cords of children he had just
delivered he performed abortions without
sufficient painkillers for poor
immigrant women his clinic was soaked in
cat urine and so messy that medical
teams couldn't evacuate patients safely
he kept fetal parts in the refrigerator
next to employee lunches this had all
the makings of a major media Malstrom a
prolific serial murder a sensational
trial innocent victims it even had
angles for non crime reporters with
troubling issues surrounding drugs
clinic regulations immigration status
and racism yet the media had to be
absolutely shamed into covering this
story in any way more than a cursory
fashion and even when major outlets
devoted a bit of coverage here and there
it was reluctant and paltry one
Washington Post reporter who had written
dozens upon dozens of stories favorable
to abortion rights groups so that she
hadn't covered Gosnell because and I
quote it was a local crime story the
idea that the national media don't cover
a local crime would be news to people
who read about the Newtown
Connecticut shootings the Trayvon Martin
killing the police shooting of Michael
Brown in Ferguson Missouri or riots in
Baltimore so whether the topic has been
religion the family human life guns
conservative governance or even sports
media bias has become more pronounced
and the trouble with accuracy an
absolute epidemic once conservatives saw
the problems they couldn't unsee them
even in the case of borne nuanced issues
such as the media downplaying massive
annual pro life marches while hyping
leftist marches reacting hysterically to
disasters that occur during Republican
admit presidencies while giving the
benefit of the doubt to the handling of
oil spills or natural disasters that
occur during democratic 10 years
spinning comments made by Republicans as
sexist and bigoted while downplaying or
trying to provide exculpatory context
for charged comments from Democrats
using anonymous sources to tear down
political opponents hiding balancing
viewpoints at the end of stories instead
of featuring them more prominently using
terms with negative connotations for
causes they dislike in terms with
positive connotations for those they
fight they favor and many other ways of
shading the truth book debt from the
perspective of conservative voters who
feel that they've been repeatedly lied
to and abused by media elites for
decades it's really not hard to
understand how we ended up with
President Trump the media however are so
unrepentant and so lacking in
self-awareness but they are having real
trouble admitting they've done anything
wrong and instead they're indulging in
their worst impulses of hyperbole and
hysteria the current political situation
is the logical result of the hostile and
distrustful environment that the press
cultivated rather than some Black Swan
event unleashed by the sudden onset of
irrationality of voters in flyover
States it was the media's decades-long
approach of putting their thumb on the
scale by covering conservatives and
conservative causes poorly that created
a lose-lose situation for conservatives
there was no way for them to operate
successfully in a system where the media
allowed them to be respected as the
principled opposition only as long as
they were shackled and limited by biased
news coverage
and conservative voters were clearly
beyond sick of it the media would say
things that weren't true cover issues
dishonestly and then accuse others of
being liars or gaffe makers for
disagreeing no candidate not even
squeaky-clean moderates such as Mitt
Romney could keep the media from
painting Republicans and their beliefs
as dangerous it was enough to make half
the country give up on the enterprise of
working with the media entirely Trump
exploited this situation he didn't
create it he made the most of it quite
literally he wrote it to the White House
or not literally but Trump voters loved
that he was beating up the bully that
they had been unable to vanquish they
loved that he destroyed the media's
power to declare things gaffes much less
campaign destroying gaffes Trump
wouldn't have had this power had the
media not set things up through decades
of shoddy coverage targeting its
political opponents the media did this
to themselves
so following Trump's surprising win the
Washington Post had a great idea and it
was something they should have probably
done a few weeks or months prior
they asked his supporters why they were
voting for him or why they voted for him
among the many interesting answers were
several that specifically mentioned the
media nicole Citro said as trump cleared
each hurdle during the campaign and i
saw how the media the establishment and
celebrities tried to derail him my hope
began to grow that I would be able to
witness their collective heads explode
when he was successful
Diane Mouse's answer was the media did
the United States a huge disservice in
covering this campaign Lorri Myers
explained I voted for Donald Trump
because the media was so incredibly
biased they were unhinged in their
obvious role as the Clinton campaign
propaganda machine the collusion was
just too much and Samantha styler said I
am a gay Millennial woman and I voted
for Donald Trump because I opposed the
political correctness movement which has
become a fascist ideology of silence and
ignorance
after months of going back and forth I
decided to listen to him directly and
not through the minced and filtered
quotes from the mainstream media clearly
something is different
Michael Crichton explains something
called gell-mann amnesia in a great
essay which is actually against him
speculation you've probably heard of it
he describes it as you open the
newspaper to an article on some subject
you know really well you read the
article and you see that the journalist
has no idea what he's talking about new
understanding of the facts or the issues
often the article is so wrong it
actually presents the story backward
reversing cause and effect you read with
exasperation or amusement the multiple
errors and then turn the page to
national or international affairs and
read it as if the rest of the newspaper
was somehow more accurate than the
baloney you just read so that's the
amnesia effect you turn the page and you
forget what you just what that you
didn't trust what they said about the
topic that you knew about Crichton noted
that people tend to discount serial
liars or exaggerator's in other areas of
life but when it comes to the media he
said we believed against evidence that
it is probably worth our time to read
other parts of the paper when in fact it
almost certainly isn't but what if the
errors are now so routine the narrative
pushing so blatant the defensive
defiance and elitism of journalists so
extreme and the partisan bias so
pronounced that people are no longer
slipping into amnesia what if they're
just done sick and tired of the entire
media industry and distrustful of many
of the stories they encounter on TV and
in newspapers and what does that mean
going forward members of the media have
enjoyed an elevated position celebrity
status II
on the theory that they would behave
responsibly with the power that they had
to police public conversations they were
to aim for objectivity civility and the
provision of important and helpful
information rather than just advanced
partisan narratives of the expense of
facts that's just gone even earlier in
2016 trust and media had hit historic
lows Gallup reported in September of
last year that Americans trust and
confidence and mass media to report the
news fully accurately and fairly dropped
to its lowest level in polling history
with only 32 percent saying they had a
great deal of trust wait that's a great
dealer like any trust yeah a great deal
or fair amount of trust in the media
that was down eight points over the
previous year among Republicans the
situation was far worse only 14% of them
had confidence in the media and that was
before what happened in November of last
year media in response are not just
continuing to do the things that have
angered people on the right but they're
doubling down on them they're openly
declaring war on the Republican
president in some cases this is further
infuriating voters on the right before
conservative voters hated the media how
they're even angrier and yet you also
have a hugely significant part of the
conservative cognoscenti who have
decided that this is not a good area to
focus on and I just wanted to look at a
few of those those arguments the
conservative response to American
rejection of a hostile media comes in
many forms
one is to disparage it with the cliche
of what about ISM so if you point out
that the media no longer have the
credibility to adjudicate to adjudicate
Donald Trump because they took an
eight-year nap while Barack Obama
violated norms associated with the
presidency you're accused of what about
ISM but politics is a continued ISM
continuum stating facts about why the
media have no credibility helps hold
people on all sides accountable the
first step to fixing a problem is to
acknowledge that you have a problem
after all another conservative critic
says that media criticism is just anti
anti Trump ISM and he says that he's
anti anti anti Trump if you can keep up
with all this he says sure the
mainstream media have been awful they
brushed stories they've airbrushed his
three they're going after Trump for
things they had no problem with under
Obama and yes they've hyperventilated
without Regis charges but so what the
media are terrible they're no worse than
they were before and Trump is worse than
other presidents according to this
critic another says yes the media are
bad but that you have to just rise above
it simply call out the media for their
violations when they arise but don't do
what Donald Trump does and another says
that the press must be supported because
shared sets of facts are important for a
functioning Republic the people going
into that people going into echo
chambers is dangerous and tribalistic so
don't attack the press and everyone come
together and learn about the importance
of the First Amendment okay well you
don't get to say that Trump is a unique
threat without demonstrating why and
just because Trump does things
differently than DC typically does
things doesn't mean that all traditions
and norms must be respected in political
discourse especially when you consider
what previous methods have gotten
conservatives with complete domination
of the media by the liberal
establishment you've got 19 trillion
dollars in deficits lengthy or some
cases unending the seemingly unending
Wars crony capitalism redefinition of
marriage tolerating the sales of organs
harvested from babies during their
abortions calling out media bias as it
comes hasn't worked and conservatives
have been doing it for 50 years networks
are more liberal than ever the data show
that journalists skew left
journalists felt empowered during the
Obama era to target ordinary Americans
and undermine Heartland Heartland values
people have legitimate reasons to feel
persecuted by the press Andrew Breitbart
was known for his media criticism said
the left doesn't win its battles in
debate it doesn't have to in the 21st
century media is everything the left
wins because it controls the narrative
the narrative is controlled by the media
the left is the media and the narrative
is everything the mainstream media
portray themselves as objective
observers of reality when they're no
such thing their partisan critical
theory hacks who think they can destroy
everything America stands for by
standing on the sidelines and